salut c'est ludo de la chaîne le tattoo
aujourd'hui je suis avec brut et on va
partir à la rencontre d'une équipe de
sportifs professionnels
les soul flies c'est eux et ça aussi
c'est
[Musique]
bref vous l'aurez compris les sauces fly
ans sont des sportifs de l'extrême
alors comment fonctionne leur discipline
commence entraîne-t-il avec brut
on vous emmène à la découverte d'un des
sports qui semblent être les plus
dangereux au monde
le volant me saute on est à chambéry
savoie parachutisme et je vais
rencontrer
fred et vince ils font partie des soul
fliers cd baissent grimpeur et
parachutistes professionnels
là on va faire du freestyle on a parlé
du programme en gros mais on va laisser
une bonne place à l'improvisation là on
va s'amuser
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le wingsuit permet donc de voler mais
alors comment ça fonctionne c'est très
simple la combinaison est en fait
constitué de trois parties les deux bras
et les jambes
ces trois partis au contact de l'air
vont se gonfle et puis se rigidifier
pour voler il existe différentes tailles
de wingsuit en fonction du saut à
effectuer soit à partir d'un avion soit
en belgique
plus la combinaison sera petite plus
elle sera maniable pour faire des
figures par exemple et plus elle sera
grande plus elle sera facile à
stabiliser utile dans le cadre d'un soir
belges utilisent d'avion comme moyen
d'entraînement on va laissant planer sur
certains move on va aller faire d'abord
parce qu'on peut les répéter on a
beaucoup plus de temps et puis une fois
qu'on les avait trouvés et ben on va
aller les reproduire en baisse jobs
alors là je vais essayer une combinaison
de wingsuit pas sauter injuste n'essayez
vraiment et voilà voir ce que ça donne
donc la tulle en file indienne moi tu
vas permettez tarn une marraine de
poitrine
on va prendre ton pied la la comme ça et
tu vas leur entrée dans le booster tu
sens la petite semaine mais je le vois
bien un plaqué sa offrant aux girondins
jusqu'en haut
j'essaie vous quand même à remonter on
va jusqu'où les gens voilà tu peux faire
des petites corrections avec ça en l'air
et mais la plupart du pilotage en fait
c'est avec l'opéra rock & roll peut
aussi le musc ambré de cambrai les
genoux et j'avais sera la main derrière
et tu viens attraper ces accords et
après tu dis en garde il faut casser sa
vitesse mais c'est ça avant de tirer
parce que si tu es à pleine vitesse et
que la combinaison elle est pressurisé
afin et ben quand tu va vouloir les
derrière eh ben ça va être tellement
gonflé que tu vas tu vas avoir du mal tu
t'entraînes ici sur un centre de
parachutisme main sur d'avion à le faire
plein de fois appelleront à l'étude
doivent tirer et c'est tout et a pas de
fantasme a déclenché automatiquement
honnêtement je le vends un poisson dans
l'eau way ou comme un écureuil et en vol
non mais douce at on envie de voler ça
donne envie évidemment de sauter et
d'essayer quoi l'homme rêve depuis
toujours de voler les premières preuves
de tentative de vol date du début du
xxème siècle en 1912 riche elle
s'inspire de la physionomie des chauves
souris pour créer un vêtement parachute
malheureusement il est mort en testant
son invention en sautant du premier
étage de la tour eiffel le 4 février de
la même année
dans les années 30 clemson met au point
une combinaison pour rallonger le temps
de chute libre
il décède le 25 avril 1937 à 26 ans lors
du festival aérien de 27 son parachute
ne s'est pas ouvert et il s'est écrasé
devant les spectateurs
c'est au début des années 90 que le
français patrick de gaillardon reprend
le concept de manière plus scientifique
il crée une combinaison aérodynamique la
pratique du vol en wingsuit moderne est
née au début ont plié des parachutes
pour faire de l'argent pour se payer des
sauts d'entraînement en progressant d'un
réussi à rentrer en équipe de france il
manque on a fait dix ans de compétition
en équipe de france on a gagné six
titres mondiaux
ouais et pendant ces années là on vivre
parce que la compétition par la justice
ça rapporte pas même si tu es champion
du monde donc
à côté de ça pour donner des cours quand
on a arrêté la compet on avait plein
d'idées en fait et puis pas trop de
moyens et on voulait se lancer dans la
réalisation d'image dans des projets on
avait on avait des rêves et on voulait
faire des trucs on faisait des indus
baie james
en parallèle on a voulu en faire de plus
en plus professionnalisé
jump et puis petit à petit on a réussi à
gagner la confiance de certains sponsors
qui nous ont permis de réaliser des
projets etc etc et maintenant ça fait
dix ans qu'on fait à ont fait que ça
imaginez on va faire nos on va fêter nos
20 ans la semaine prochaine
vingt ans de saut en sans attendre ce
poney quelque chose comme ça à faire du
26 mai l'ensemble
il est huit heures du matin je suis à
côté de la clusaz et j'attends fred et
vince qui vont faire un saut en baisse
jump et combinaisons wingsuit depuis ce
point là au salut tu vas bien ouais
super génial alors qu'est ce qu'on fait
c'est pas le programme idées cette volée
donc dans cette tombe sur toute la
partie en merde qu'on voit là jusqu'à
finir au niveau des cailloux qui sont là
et puis ouvrir les parachutes à côté de
la ferme et se poser près des vaches
en gros je vais devoir monter jusque là
bas est normalement ils vont mettre les
trois que donc on est plus l'ascension
de la montagne c'est parti vous êtes
dans quel état d'esprit là juste avant
le saut bon sens plutôt bien
ouais voilà bon mois d'un match c'est
toujours sympa on discute un petit peu
de la ligne de voile c'est un moment
aussi de détente où tu veux parler un
petit peu tout en pleine nature en
personne pour déranger le vol il
s'adapte vraiment au terrain et au spot
donc en fonction de la pente en fonction
de comment les montagnes elles sont
placées de voilà vraiment en fonction du
terrain on va prévoir le saut sur des
sauts comme ça on a on a un plan ouais
et on le respecte la météo elle est
importante dans ce sport à bas la météo
les plus qu'importante est crucial
surtout quand tu fais des sceaux en
montagne 21 encore plus tributaires de
la météo c'est sûr que les prévisions
regarder un petit peu en avance ce qui
va se passer ça nous aide beaucoup
mais après tu peux pas enlever le mot
monde tu vas arriver sur place et tu vas
pouvoir regarder un bonbon au delà de la
chute libre qui est déjà une sensation
de dengue pouvoir maintenant planer dans
des pentes le long des reliefs le long
des falaises
c'est dur à expliquer quoi on peut
regarder beaucoup de vidéos mais c'est
ce qu'on vit quand on le fait ouais ça
doit être fou c'est complètement fou ça
donne trop envie de recommencer
est-ce que après mille cinq cents en
base jump même après ça on a toujours
peur ou pas quand on saute
ouais il ya toujours une peur c'est sûr
forme de peur ouais c'est sympa c'est
pas naturel de jetés d'une falaise
d'accord on est très concentré
avant le départ et la peur ça permet de
ça permet de rester en vie voilà le jour
où on n'aura plus peur et où tu te rends
pas compte du danger
c'est là où tu es c'est là où tu es
vraiment en danger en fait je viens
d'arriver à mon spot où je vais les
attendre à peu près à la moitié du
chemin pour eux ce qu'ils vont passer à
côté de moi en wingsuit et ils sont tous
là bas tout là bas là bas
[Musique]
on est au top
et voilà comme marié fermé be there
3 2 1
[Musique]
non
c'était génial de pouvoir les voir aussi
près ça faisait un moment qu'on avait
cette idée là en tête et qu'on voulait
le faire et ça a très bien marché on
s'est régalé une fois de plus ce gavage
légère tremblote genre décembre de la
montée d'adrénaline
mathieu c'est un peu moins bon que votre
jour mais un tu vois il ya quand même
sympa ça passe large on s'est laissé une
demi seconde d'écart et puis ça a fait
que j'aurais laissé plus je te répondrai
pas c'est vraiment cool de pouvoir
mettre des gens dans la pente et volée à
côté pour eux ça fait un joli spectacle
et pour nous ça fait des points de
référence et du coup c'est vraiment
sympa qui sont passé tellement près
c'est incroyable mais un hyper
impressionnant la vitesse et le bruit je
pensais pas que ça fait autant de bruit
en fait ouais bah on est calandri quand
même à 150 km heure c'est un sport qui
essaie sur engagé mais qui peut être
fait en sécurité si on respecte son
briefing si on respecte son entraînement
si on respecte le spot sur lequel on va
et sauter par rapport à son niveau
les gens en fait ils voient l'étape
finale voilà qu'à la voix leur a soutenu
que la vidéo sur youtube avec un mec tu
vois un qui rase le sol wes et des
balades sauf que pour en arriver là il
ya combien de l'année étape faut que le
grand public puisse réussir un petit peu
un distingué un petit peu de la masse
d'informations qui assurent le web
maintenant et des gens qui font
n'importe quoi et puis bah ce qui qui
essaye de rester de rester en vie et
puis de montrer une image positive de
notre porte
on ne connaît pas exactement le nombre
de personnes qui pratiquent le wingsuit
en france le belge et le wingsuit sont
des disciplines qui ne nécessite pas de
licence à proprement parler n'importe
qui peut demain s'il en a envie acheter
une voile et partir faire un saut mais
ces disciplines peuvent être très
dangereuses
il ya des accidents mortels chaque année
il est donc nécessaire d'avoir un
entraînement acharné et des conseils de
professionnels pour pouvoir effectuer sa
en toute sécurité
temps frais je pense juste raison que
toi
'le soit en parachute c'est pas naturel
de sauter d'un avion
le fait d'avoir fred et vince à mes
côtés ça me rassure beaucoup après qui
m'ont avoué qu'il pourrait rien faire
c'est un problème mais ce qui m'a
beaucoup moins rationnel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà
[Musique]
vous
plus
c'était alors vraiment les gars eux
c'est l'une des meilleures expériences
que j'ai faits de match des nordistes
est la grosse grêle main et tous ces
derniers niel des sensations ça je ne
m'attendais pas vraiment pas un truc
aussi fou quoi c'est énorme c'est en
question n'était en kiff tous ensemble
c'est énorme apparaît la grosse teuf je
vais en refaire un obligé obligé son
site web sa remontée vous avez un sport
de rêve
ils ont le meilleur métier du monde
parce que c'est leur passion le saut en
parachute le wingsuit le base jump c'est
leur passion et ils arrivent à vivre
j'ai appris énormément de choses
déjà il ya tout un truc autant la
sécurité que on se doute pas forcément
on pense que les mecs ils arrivent ils
soient de points et met pas du tout en
fait c'est ça qui est fou c'est que
c'est ultra calculé tout ça en fait
c'est un sport à part entière vraiment
[Musique]